president Richard erdogan is starting
his third term in office after beating
kamalu in the runoff on Sunday he won
more than 52 percent of the vote and
that's been described as one of the most
important and closely contested in
decades let's get more on this from Sami
zidane who's following events for us
from Istanbul and and Sammy let's just
begin with sort of the number of
challenges ahead uh for president
erdogan the list is long
right the list is long and the list is
challenging itself not least of which
you could start with the economy the
state of the economy here something it's
on the minds of many if not all Turks
when you just go to the shops and look
at prices how much they've been rising
over the last few months even years well
inflation is uh by the last monthly
count was around 40 something percent
and authorities would argue that's down
from a peak of over 80 in October of
last year but that's still relatively
high and you feel the difference just in
the few weeks that go by you see prices
go up and you it takes a bite out of
people's pockets so no doubt president
will have to think of something to try
and get that under control you've heard
him in his speech last night his victory
speech arguing that hey we know how to
get inflation under control we've done
it before we'll do it again but the
question when you put it to some of the
Orthodox economists they say how long
can the Central Bank go on propping up
the Lira which is the price that the
economy is paying when the Lira weakens
and we saw that actually after the
election result was announced that Leo
did weaken to the dollar and the central
bank trying to prop It Up by selling its
reserves well we got the the news just a
few days ago that it's dipped into
negative territory how long can that go
on for so that's something that's going
to require his attention there's the
issue of course of the Fallout of that
earthquake which hit this country back
in February and March the series of
earthquakes now the government has
promised that it's going to rebuild and
rebuild soon homes entire cities will be
rebuilt in some cases
relocated so a lot of expectations are
going to be high there for ready one to
deliver and you've got to remember also
the question of divisiveness according
to the organization of security and
cooperation in Europe they just released
a statement a few hours ago noting that
both sides used an extremely divisive
campaign rhetoric during the campaigning
for these elections and if you just look
at the results it's clearly with such a
high turnout and such a close call
between the two candidates it's clear
creation of a very divided public
it is Sammy I mean elections in any
democracy never really end but what
wonders where does the opposition go now
and what's their next goal
[Music]
that's a big question and already we're
starting to see some of the key figures
within the opposition Camp perhaps
addressing that one figure would be the
mayor of Istanbul who is from the
opposition from the main opposition
party
and he's been talking several times
since the election results come out he's
been talking about change and he's
actually called for a gathering today in
Istanbul to talk about what we can do
next and he's been dropping hints about
how it basically doesn't make sense to
keep on doing the same thing and
expecting to get a different result now
some people are interpreting that as
perhaps he's hinting at a change within
the party within its leadership and
that's raising questions over the future
of the current leader of the jehepe
which has come out and whether he can
continue to lead this party given the
failure that we saw yesterday there's
also a question mark about the
opposition Alliance the so-called table
of six now they had a lot of
disagreements before this election and
there is some question about whether
this Alliance can hold it together going
forward well clearly there was a lot at
stake for both sides in this election as
I explained in this report
foreign
one of the most important fights in a
political career spanning three decades
a loss would have been the end of an era
a win would cement his legacy as one of
the most powerful leaders in modern day
turkia
Rajiv Tai burdwan told the Gathering of
supporters to have faith in the future
we aren't the only winners of this
election the entire nation is turkey is
the winner today the victory belongs to
everyone it belongs to our democracy the
only losers are terrorist organizations
plotting against turkey as for the
responsibility bestowed upon us by our
nation there are no heartbreaks on our
part we aren't angry at anyone now it's
time to leave all disputes behind and
unite behind our national values and
dreams the runoff vote was also a
crucial moment for his rival backed by
an alliance of six opposition parties
Kamal kalistarolo had promised to fix
the economy restore the parliamentary
system and ensure greater freedoms
opposition parties are wrapping their
minds around what went wrong they
initially thought people would vote with
their wallets that a change of heart in
earthquake devastated areas would be to
their advantage but that didn't happen
now they need to move past anger and
frustration and perhaps consider a
complete reset of the fragile Alliance
they built for the election
[Applause]
I couldn't let our nation fall into
battle with another and I didn't do that
I couldn't allow our nation to suffer
from poverty and economic challenges for
your rights I have always fought and I
will continue to do so we will continue
to fight for democracy and I am asking
you to join us in our efforts
urduan is celebrating the man who's
dominated Turkish politics this Century
faces a tough task ahead reducing
skyrocketing inflation rebuilding entire
cities and improving strained relations
with the West the governing party and
its allies have retained the
Parliamentary majority that gives
erdogan enough support to deliver on the
promises he made during the election
campaign
and people rallied in the streets of
Turkish neighborhoods in Berlin to
celebrate erdogan's third term in office
Germany is home to the largest Turkish
despora president erdogan has a strong
voter base there Let's cross over to
Dominic Kane who's in Berlin for us it
seems they were quite influential in
terms of the final vote Dominic
certainly the electorate that can vote
in Germany in Turkish elections is very
considerable more than one and a half
million people are eligible to vote in
Turkish elections in this country in the
events perhaps around just over half of
them actually did vote and two-thirds of
the more than two-thirds of those who
voted voted for President erdogan and in
this part of Berlin from where I'm
broadcasting right now this is koitzberg
a part of the city with a large Turkish
Community there were many people
celebrating here on Sunday evening as
indeed in other areas of Berlin but it
is worth making the point that not
everybody in this country who could vote
did vote for the president or to
re-elect the president and that's
reflected in some of the opinions that
we've been Gathering here on the streets
of Berlin today
I'm very happy with the election result
because I think in the past 20 years
compared to the 80s and the 90s A lot
has changed for the better even though
of course in the past five or six years
with inflation and the numbers of
refugees some things have changed for
the worse as
no future for the Turkish people but
unfortunately they don't understand that
I'm really annoyed with the Turkish
people living here
the official reaction to the result of
the election here in Germany while
Chancellor Schultz tweeted
congratulations to president erdogan and
stressed the importance of the
relationship between the two countries
similar sentiments coming from other EU
leaders perhaps the most ringing
endorsement as it were from Victor Orban
from Hungary saying this was an
unquestionable victory for president
erdogan but there are some voices in
Germany who don't necessarily share that
view certainly even within the cabinet
of Olaf Schultz chem erstemia a German
cabinet minister from the green party
who has Turkish Heritage said seeing the
scenes of jubilant erdogan supporters in
Berlin to him represented their
rejection of Germany's pluralist
democracy and one final thought from an
influential European member upon a
member of the European Parliament
Manfred Weber from the Bavarian
Christian social Union saying
effectively that the EU should now do
away with any suggestion of accession
talks with turkey and try to have a more
normal relationship with the Turks
Turkish government that is not acceding
to the EU
Dominic Kane in Berlin for us thank you